thank you as well to our Deputy Attorney
General rod Rosenstein for being here
flew down together the press wants to
know why did you talk about but we had a
very good talk I will say that became a
very big story actually folks we had a
good talk boy did that keep people
guessing today that was President Trump
surprising a lot of folks with this
newfound support for Deputy Attorney
General rod Rose design the man
overseeing the robert muller probe
joining us now to react is california
congressman house Intel committee chair
Devon Nunez congressman thanks for being
here tonight what do you make of the
president's comments on the Deputy
Attorney General today that was a that
was kind of interesting yeah look I
don't think any of us think that
Rosenstein should be dismissed before
the elections I think he does have to
come in this week and answer whether or
not he was willing to wear a wire or not
and whether or not he was looking at
invoking the 25th amendment those are
key questions that he's going to answer
before the Russia task force this week
supposedly on Thursday Devon the issue
of this redacted series of documents
regarding the Russia probe people
watching across the country like okay
you guys are always talking about this
documents that are going to be
declassified and then they're not or
they're partially Declassified and we
talked about this a few weeks ago and
I'm still not following what happened
the Deputy Attorney General with a few
others from the Intel community
convinced the president correct me if
I'm wrong not to declassify documents
about the FISA warrant against Carter
page and other renewals of that warrant
and kicked it over to the Inspector
General correct what else do we know
about this yeah that's correct and so
you know that's really my biggest
problem with the Department of Justice
and the FBI is that every time we try to
get something out to the public they cry
wolf and they claim there's going to be
national security implications so the
president was very clear said that these
documents need to
be immediately declassified without
redactions then what happened is is that
a meeting occurred that you just just
referred to and then suddenly the IG was
brought in now my challenge with the IG
I don't have anything against the IG IG
is probably a great guy but we're
Congress we believe that people have a
right to know this information needs to
be made public it's not very much
information and we want the president to
declassify it the president has
mentioned that he would so this is now
been I think two and a half three weeks
so it doesn't take that long Laura
you're only talking about twenty pages
of a FISA and I think about a dozen FBI
reports from no other than Bruce or
whose wife Nellie or was working for the
Clinton campaign effectively and helping
to feed the information into the FBI so
I just don't know what they're thinking
here the president I think you know is a
smart guy but he needs to be careful
about who he listens to I think
sometimes Adam Schiff is all is all over
this as you might imagine let's watch
the single act of using a never-before
house truehl to selectively release
classified information in the
now-infamous núñez memorandum was a
violation of everything that the
committee has stood for it was a naked
politicization of intelligence and a
fraudulent one at that talking about
that particular issue just making it
personal basically about you I know
you're used to this and you're in a you
know you're running for re-election and
the Democrats are gonna make you out to
be the boogeyman here but at this point
it seems to me that Americans have a
right to know what the heck happened and
why an American citizen was spied upon
using documents that were created at the
funding of the president's opponent
during the campaign yeah so remember the
entire Democratic Party okay and the
media their friends in the media which
is pretty much all of them except for
10% and all the bad people from the
Clinton ministration that were funneling
this stuff in the FBI you've got a dozen
people now the FBI and DOJ who are gone
so everything that we did
our committee we had to do we had to
make sure the American public knew that
this information about what somebody was
doing to basically set up a campaign and
accuse them of colluding with Russians
was really wrong and you know we've now
proven that the only collusion that
happened was collusion with the
Democrats and the Klan the Clinton
campaign and the Russians and I'll tell
you you know I still want to know why
nobody's investigating what Russians
were the Democrats in the Clinton
campaign talking to through fusion GPS
and feeding that information into the
FBI and now we know that broke last week
and you kind of alluded to it earlier
Laura that the top lawyer for the FBI
commis lawyer James Baker was meeting
with a top lawyer from the DNC and I'm
sorry that just doesn't smell good to me
well I mean yeah I mean as a lawyer for
the FBI you can't be having political
hour meetings that even have the
appearance of being political in the
middle of this type of investigation
Devon noon yes thanks for taking some
time tonight we really appreciate it I
know we'll check back with you soon